Lead is a very soft metal and it’s easily
moulded into all sorts
of shapes. This is a pot, I’m not sure what
it is from, I got it
from an old lab that was being closed down
so it was
probably made for holding a strong acid because
lead is very
unreactive. You can see rather nicely here
the white colour of
lead oxide because it has oxidised over the
years and this is
the white material that was used for paints.
This white lead paint that people use, the
oxide of lead, had
one rather unfortunate consequence that it
reacts with
sulphur in the air and in Victorian times
when people burnt
coal they produced a lot of sulphur, and the
sulphur reacted
with the lead to give a black colour which
made the white
paint eventually turn grey and if you waited
long enough
black. And this effect was exploited by one
of my former
colleagues here Professor Leslie Crombie,
who during the war
was working for the British admiralty in their
research labs on
the camouflaging of submarines. Now if you
want your
submarine not to be seen, when it is well
away from the
coast it needs to be white because if you
have a white
submarine it does not show up against the
sky but, if you are
trying to slip into the coast at night and
not be seen you need
the submarine to be black. So Leslie came
up with the idea of
painting the submarine with lead oxide and
when it was going
near the coast, some sailors went out on to
the outside of the
ship and sloshed over a solution of sulphide
and seawater and
the paint turned black. And so you could then
go into the
coast, drop your agent, do whatever secret
things you
wanted to do, and then when you went away
from the coast
they sloshed hydrogen peroxide with seawater,
which turned
the sulphite into sulphate, and lead sulphate
is white so your
submarine went white again. So you could change
the colour
of your submarine to suit what you were doing
in the military
operation and nobody would see you.
And that was a real thing that happened?
Yes, that was a real thing. I don’t know
how widely it was
used but they actually tried it out and it
worked. So they just
needed to take the chemicals and they could
add the
seawater to make the solution to put on the
submarine.
The other very important property of lead
is that because the
lead atom is heavy it is very good at stopping
radioactive
particles particularly alpha particles, which
are helium nuclei
those are the nucleus of the helium atom,
or beta particles
which are electrons.
What you should find that if we put this in
the way, it should
stop counting almost immediately so let us
see if that works.
There we go straight back down to background
and if we take
it away, and it picks back up again.
And so people who are working with radioactive
samples used
to use, and still use, bricks made out of
lead. So here are two
of the bricks and you can see this is a small
one and this one
is rather thinner. The problem is that if
you start building
these bricks into a wall, there is always
a chance that when
you have two bits together there might be
a slight gap
between the two bricks and some of the radioactive
particles
may go between them. So to avoid this the
bricks are made
with groves in it, and a pointed part here,
so that when you
put them together there is absolutely no way
that anything
can go through because you can’t have a
direct line through
it. Now the trouble is of course you can’t
see anything
through it, so if you have an experiment where
you want to
handle radioactive material inside a container
and manipulate
it you can’t make the whole container of
lead because you
can’t see what is going on inside. And so
for that, people
have developed lead glass, of which this is
a sample and it is
immensely heavy, but this is glass and there
is really a large
amount of lead that has been put in it. And
some of the fancy
crystals that your grandmothers or your ancestors
might have
had, had a bit of lead in the glass. This
has got a really high
proportion of lead in the glass which is probably
why the
glass is yellow rather than the white colour
that you normally
have with glass. But windows like this can
be used for
handling really quite radioactive materials
behind them. The
colour is rather nice isn’t it?
Good.
But it is very heavy, so…
Well, lead has had a very long history; it
was one of the first
metals to be widely used. The Romans used
this for drinking
materials. There is also lead acetate, that
is a compound of
lead and vinegar is meant to taste sweet and
the Romans
added this to their wine to make it sweeter.
The fact that it
was really very poisonous and caused, possibly
even caused
madness, was not really widely recognised.
In fact some
people have suggested that part of the collapse
of the Roman
Empire was due to too much lead. Lead was
very widely used
in the UK for water pipes because it’s easy
to manufacture
and to join together. It tends not to have
been very
dangerous in terms of drinking water because
it gets a
coating on the surface so you do not get much
lead in the
water; though if you do have a house with
lead pipes in, it is
usually advisable to change them. It’s again,
it was used very
widely from the 1920s up till the late 70s
or 80s as an
additive for petrol. In the old days when
petrol engines were
first introduced, when you came to a hill
and put down the
accelerator of your car, the engine started
misfiring, so-called
‘pinking’, and the whole thing shook.
So it was really quite
difficult to drive up hills, but then it was
discovered that you
could put in a compound, so-called tetraethyl
lead, which was
really very poisonous, but the guy who discovered
it washed
his hands in public at a press conference
saying “look it’s so
safe”, despite the fact that there were
people dying in his
factory. So it was very widely adopted and
so it was only in
quite recent times that it was realised how
much lead was
being blown out into the atmosphere in car
exhausts. And so
it’s now almost everywhere we have lead-free
petrol as a
result of people realising the poison-ness
of lead.